[Music]
hi everyone
so today i'm really excited to tell you
about one of my favorite topics
which is how we can use deep
reinforcement learning in the field of
fluid dynamics
in the last couple of videos i've told
you about reinforcement learning
and reinforcement learning with deep
neural networks or deep learning
and so today we're going to talk about
some of the many applications
in the field of fluid mechanics so here
i have one of my favorite videos of this
eagle
flying in an unsteady turbulent gust
field
and you can almost see the eagle feeling
the wind
and manipulating the vorticity in this
case
to gently glide onto a rock okay
so this is an extremely hard control
problem and it's the kind of thing that
we as
human engineers might want to be able to
reproduce or mimic the capability of
in in our systems so uh
biological systems are extremely good at
interacting with complex fluid
environments from fish
to birds and bats even flying insects
and so how they do this uh has for a
long time for thousands of years
been a mystery to humans and has also
motivated
much of our own engineering design and
thinking
so it's really exciting that this
biologically inspired idea of
reinforcement learning
is now starting to tell us uh kind of
how we might interact with and control
these complex systems
so just a very very brief reminder of
kind of the
the setup for reinforcement learning so
we have our agent
in this case our eagle interacting with
some environment
our unsteady flow field
it has a state that it measures it
measures its state of the world
through its uh through its eyes through
its vision
also through the sensing on its wings so
maybe it can feel
a bit of the flow field and it has some
policy
for how it decides its actions based on
what it's sensing about the current
state
the past states and what it thinks the
future states are going to be
and it's trying to maximize some reward
and this is a pretty abstract reward in
the sense that it could be
um you know catching a fish or not
banging its talons on the rock when it
lands or spending as little energy as
possible
while maintaining um you know kind of a
patrol over an area
and my wife is a neuroscientist and she
pointed out actually that the reward
in biological systems is not actually
coming from the environment
in biological learning systems the
reward is actually internal to the
organism so we
release dopamine when something good
happens when we're happy
and that is the kind of internal
reinforcement signal in biological
systems
so this is a little different than the
biological uh reinforcement learning but
this is kind of
our playground uh when we want to
simulate these things and design them
ourselves
and so one of the things we're going to
do um so of course we have our policy
there's some value function where the
eagle you know estimates what its future
benefit is going to be based on some
control action
and in deep reinforcement learning we're
essentially replacing
a lot of what's going on under the hood
with the eagle
with this deep neural network where we
measure the state
and we make some informed decision about
a good policy that will get us kind of
maximal
rewards in the future okay so
what i'm going to do is i'm going to go
through some vignettes of examples of
reinforcement learning in the field of
fluid dynamics
and this is just a small snapshot and
i'm sure
even when this video comes out there
will be new examples
to discuss so this is just kind of an
instant in time
now a lot of what i'm going to talk
about we did discuss in our review paper
in the annual review of fluid mechanics
on machine learning for fluid mechanics
and in particular
we talked about kind of this deep
reinforcement learning scheme
and how this can be used in fluid
dynamic applications
and we tried to separate out those
applications into
applications where you are directly
manipulating the fluid so flow control
to reduce drag or increase lift other
applications where you're trying to
kind of mimic some biological activity
like schooling or flocking
and then another kind of paradigm of
deep reinforcement learning
is where you're learning flight dynamic
control and so there is a fluid
kind of that you're inside of and
there's unsteady fluid dynamics for this
you know for your glider or your
quadrotor but you're kind of abstracting
that out and you're trying to make a
high level control scheme
for a robot okay and so i i'm just going
to highlight one of my favorite works on
this uh which
is this paper by verma novati and
kumitsakis
in pnas 2018 where essentially what they
did
was apply deep reinforcement learning
on a very very
sophisticated three-dimensional
simulation of fish
in different configurations to see if
trailing fish can harness energy
from uh from the leading fish can they
uh kind of school
or or tail fish efficiently can you um
kind of build a control lot to do that
let's see if i can play this again just
so you can see
now this highlights some of the
challenges in applying reinforcement
learning for fluid mechanics
so first off this is an extremely
high dimensional simulation the state
space
is you know i think in this case must be
on the order of millions possibly even
billions
uh of discrete elements that you would
need to simulate this fluid
so very very high dimensional non-linear
environment
the individual agents probably only have
very limited measurements of
that environment so they are going to
only measure you know a little bit so
for example fish have a lateral line
which is kind of a pressure sensitive
line and that's what they get to measure
about the surrounding fluid flow and so
these simulations are extremely
expensive to run and we know that
reinforcement learning requires a lot of
kind of trial and error
so you need a lot of simulations and so
this is extremely extremely expensive
currently
and there are lots of efforts to speed
this up and to make this more efficient
using reduced order modeling and things
like that but i'm really really
impressed by this work
and there's a ton of great work coming
out of petrus kumitsakis's group
this is just one of many papers they
were among the first to do this
in the field of fluid mechanics good um
so another kind of area i like to think
about that is related this also comes
out of petros's lab
is using reinforcement learning for
speeding up computational architectures
so i told you that that big simulation
of those fish
was basically a super computer
computation um like a real kind of feat
of
of computational strength so in this
paper
they actually use reinforcement learning
in a clever way
to try to speed up those supercomputer
computations
of turbulent systems and so in this case
i don't have time to really dive into
kind of the nitty-gritty here going to
the hood but i encourage you to read
this
these blue cells which are pretty
sparsely
spaced out in the computational domain
essentially use multi-agent
reinforcement
reinforcement learning to learn kind of
how
the flow interacts on these sparse grid
points to fill in
kind of the details and the statistics
of this much higher resolution grid
so the upshot is that you can get away
with much much fewer computations on
these kind of sparse
elements uh but still have the ability
to capture some of the high dimensional
dynamics at a fraction of the cost so i
think that's a very cool idea
this fits into the closure modeling
turbulence closure modeling field called
sub grid scale modeling where
essentially these blue elements are
sampled at
kind of coarser than the finest
resolution you would need to resolve all
of the turbulence
and this multi-agent reinforcement
learning is acting as a closure model
in that scenario so again this is a lot
of kind of deep stuff i'll hopefully
talk
more about large eddy simulations and
subgrid scale modeling later
but i encourage you to check this out
okay so you can use reinforcement
learning to mimic
swimming and schooling you can use it to
speed up computational architectures in
fluids
i'm going to point out another excellent
review paper
um this is one of my favorites and i
highly recommend you check this out
i've been following the work of of
revolt for
for a while and they do some really
great reinforcement learning for fluids
what i want to point out here is that
they cover a lot
of examples in the literature and they
talk about what algorithms they use
kind of how they actually enact these
reinforcement learning
algorithms in practice so for example we
just pointed out the
verma 2018 and so
most of these algorithms are using some
variation of q-learning ql is q-learning
or a deep-q network a few different ones
proximal policy optimization
a3c i think is asynchronous advantageous
actor critic so there's a few different
ones but most of these are q learning
okay and i actually learned of some new
applications uh just in
in reading this paper recently okay good
um so a couple of other examples that i
want to talk about
are how you can use
this reinforcement learning to control
the fluid itself
so instead of just being an agent in the
fluid like my fish
what if we actually want to do flow
control and manipulate the fluid itself
so often times in this flow past a
cylinder
or you know this is mimicking the fluid
flow past a truck
or an airplane or a ship where you might
want to decrease the drag
to increase efficiency so in this great
paper
they essentially do that with
reinforcement learning
and what they're able to do is get a
substantially decreased
drag coefficient so this is much much
lower drag
on those bodies just by applying
reinforcement learning
for control in a clever way and remember
reinforcement learning is essentially
the intersection of machine learning
and control theory so very very useful
for flow control
good some other examples where people
have
used this for for controlling the fluid
directly this is a very cool recent
paper
where they uh numerically and
experimentally
manipulate the drag on these bluff
bodies on these kind of wake flows
using active reinforcement learning
control and i put the significance
statement up here i think it's very nice
uh kind of summary of the problem and
you know they're able to reduce the drag
by 30 percent
very quickly in these simulations and
experiments
so i think i have a figure here good
this is a snapshot
um before training halfway through
training
and column c is after training and you
can essentially see that the wake
behind the cylinder that's the bottom
row here
is kind of evolving as the system is
learning and what you can actually see
is that it is
learning to kind of trip it to
turbulence and create a more
uh streamlined wake so you know that's
something that
people who throw baseballs you know have
kind of learned how to do
in some ways very cool results
uh and then actually in reading that
review paper
i i hadn't been aware of this this paper
that was in siggraph in 2018 but
i found this after reading their review
paper and it's an absolutely beautiful
demonstration
of kind of learning different control
strategies in a simulated environment
to use fluids to manipulate objects i'm
just going to let this play for a while
because it's
pretty awesome and i was you know
unaware of this
of this work really really like this
and this is like a four minute video the
link is down here so
please you know check it out yourself
there's way way more
kind of cool stuff that they do here in
this video
i'm just going to see a little more the
rigid body balancing i think is really
nice
so they're going to kind of balance this
thing up and there's you know there's
more examples
okay good um so the last example that i
i want to go into and i've mentioned
this very briefly in my deep
reinforcement learning video
is this application of uh using
reinforcement learning for
flight in an unsteady fluid environment
so we already saw the fish schooling
that is you know using reinforcement
learning
to control an agent a fish in a fluid
environment
now we're going to look at how people
have actually designed
controllers for quad rotors helicopters
gliders
in real uh unsteady fluid environments
and this is kind of where the the rubber
hits the road
you know connecting back to that eagle
flying
so some of the earliest work uh here was
done
uh in berkeley and stanford
uh where they essentially reproduce
these very very
aggressive acrobatic maneuvers of these
quadrotors
so they essentially have a human expert
training and
flying these things in these crazy
acrobatics and then with reinforcement
learning they can essentially
learn to mimic those acrobatic maneuvers
and this is some of the earliest work i
mean really ahead of its time 2004
neribs 2007 europe's and so on
really great work uh a related work also
uh pretty early on was uh by tedrick at
all learning to fly like a bird
and i really like this one because i
think you can see it there's a
an airplane here like a model airplane
and they're learning to
perch in an unstable an unsteady fluid
environment you can see the fluid here
and you can see this thing learning to
stall its wings and perch
uh on a ledge this is a very complicated
maneuver this is something that we see
birds do all the time when they perch
uh on a telephone wire but this is
extremely hard uh
for you know for engineered systems to
do so like i wouldn't recommend a human
try to do this in an airplane this seems
like very dangerous
to stall your wings out create a huge
separated vortex to simultaneously
increase your lift
as you decrease your dr you increase
your drag and slow down for
this nice gentle perch maneuver but with
reinforcement learning they
were able to learn uh this this very
complex maneuver really cool paper
another great one this is out of eth
2017
control of a quadrotor with
reinforcement learning
and there's a lot of groups that are
doing really cool stuff here i know
jonathan howe's group
at mit is doing really nice work with uh
with
kind of advanced machine learning
control for quadrotors um
but i think this is just a really nice
you know kind of learns these aggressive
maneuvers and
and disturbance rejection okay
another great one that is pretty recent
i think this is 2016.
it looks like it came out by ready at
all
is essentially learning to soar in
turbulent environments so what they do
is they take
a model of a bird and they put it in a
chaotic
rayleigh bernard convective flow so hot
uh on the bottom
cool on the top this is a model for you
know when when it starts being daylight
in the planes
the ground heats up and it creates these
large thermal convection cells
and hunting birds or carrion birds
will glide and rise on these thermals
and then they will
essentially patrol over an area looking
for small
prey and things like that and so panel a
is before
their reinforcement learning training
and panel b is after their reinforcement
learning
you can see that they've essentially
learned to use these thermals
for very efficient climb in these
unstable
unsteady fluid environments really
really cool work i mean i'm a huge
fan of all of this and it kind of blows
me away that in such a short time you
know so much has been done
okay another great one learning to fly i
believe this one is also out of
out of mit this is a really neat one
where they
you know they take off they hover or
they glide they land you know it's
really
pretty sophisticated okay so what we
have seen
is that reinforcement learning
especially deep reinforcement learning
can be used to understand and control
complex fluid environments
and so there's a few perspectives so we
can control an
agent interacting in a fluid environment
like a fish or like a glider
we can directly manipulate the fluid
environment itself
for example in flow control applications
and so i think that this is going to be
an area of
massive massive development in the next
decades reinforcement learning certainly
has been in robotics
it is a very robust biologically
inspired way
to learn how to interact with a very
complex system and so i think this is
only going to kind of increase
in how useful and how kind of central
this is
in fluid engineering in the future okay
so with that i would like
to conclude thank you very much